Star Trek has been quite divisive of
Link it's released some episodes that
people have loved and others that people
have hated but actually is that a good
thing welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
so I have not hidden the fact that I
have not actually enjoyed the musical
episode of Star Trek
hated it in bits the boy band Klingon
thing I couldn't I could not stand that
moment to that episode it really
actually made me physically angry
on the whole though I thought the
episode was was okay I liked a couple of
the songs I liked they at least tried to
make it sci-fi by having a scientific
explanation for what was happening
I think the reason they gave was kind of
a nonsense but they tried so that's the
main thing
um so it got me thinking though
particularly after speaking to Mark
Cartier on the shuttlepod show last
night is it actually a good thing or a
bad thing because what is the
alternative to Star Trek making bold
risky decisions like this well the
alternative is we get Bland boring safe
science fiction where they don't try to
do anything too risky
and surely nobody wants that
so I'm wondering whether it is actually
a good thing that Star Trek was brave
enough to do things like a musical now I
will still argue and I'm not going to
change my mind on this
that this season of strange new worlds
has maybe been a little bit too much
risk and a little bit too much you know
crazy Antics rather than actually Star
Trek
I do wonder if the final episode is
going to be a surprise double episode
Maybe
we'll know in a couple of days so by the
time you've watched this you might
already know but it just seems really
odd to me that they've done episode nine
of this season as this risky musical
episode when they've still then got to
do the finale
I'd have thought the musical would have
made more sense it's maybe like a bonus
episode 11 or like I keep saying like
this as a Christmas special or something
I would have thought that made more
sense
but maybe the finale will be two hours
because then actually everyone's happy
because I do think that this episode
nine should have been a build up to the
big finale episode and obviously it
hasn't been they do seem to be trying to
do a different Star Trek series for
different demographics or different
groups of Star Trek fans we have strange
new worlds which is a bit more fun a bit
cheeky you get a lot of episodes like
this with a bit of fun in them a lot of
risks we have discovery which is way
more drama a lot of action very serious
we get lower decks which is a love
letter to TNG fans but also fans that
enjoy a bit more uh humor and they're
still plenty of Canon in there and we
obviously had Prodigy there was a lot of
Canon stuff going on in there we saw the
end of the Enterprise E for example but
obviously it was aimed more a younger
audience
so they do seem to be trying to keep
everyone happy as a rule with Star Trek
Now by having lots of different shows
going on at once they can do that
the risk is though that if you only have
one of two shows that you try and keep
everybody happy within that show
and the only way to do that is to not
take those risks now I would argue
that when they took the decision to do
the musical they must have known this is
going to be divisive they must have
known it was going to upset people and
they did it anyway I'm wondering if
that's one of the problems with marvel
at the moment
they're so worried about upsetting
certain aspects of the fandom that
they're just not tanking those risks now
obviously at the moment Hollywood has a
lot of things to deal with with the
strikes Etc but also it had major
scandals with sort of like the me too
movement it has been horribly sexist and
horribly racist for pretty much his
entire existence and it is trying to
figure out how to resolve those problems
entertainment is there just to entertain
us in lots of ways but it is also a
mirror of society always has been and
always will be so in that respect our
entertainment has to try and grapple
with these problems marvelous tried to
do that in one way by just being very
inclusive but by doing that it's been
very careful not to offend anyone in the
process and by doing that it's offended
a lot of people
because the people that shout woke at
things now I don't agree with them
probably 70 or 80 of the time but
sometimes they do have a point TV shows
are so desperate to include every
demographic
to talk about sexism racism the lgbtq
plus communities issues as much as
humanly possible include all of it in
their TV shows and movies
that they tend to forget the story a
little bit
and that is frustrating when an agenda
overtakes good storytelling there is a
problem and the woke Community the
people that shout woken all these things
are just getting more and more angry
about that now this community that a
shouting work and everything is
fortunately as well they do have a large
proportion of bigots within them that I
get comments from people all the time
and they're very thoughtful sensible
people saying look I'm not racist I'm
not a sexist I'm not an anything I just
want my TV to actually focus on the
story rather than all these agendas
I have other people commenting that have
agendas themselves Unfortunately they
are racist they are sexist they might
try to hide their bigotry behind certain
words and they can really hide behind
the woke agenda to hide their bigotry
but they still are bigots and while they
are shouting as loudly as the rest
unfortunately the sensible voices the
people actually do appreciate that there
is a problem in Hollywood that needs
solving are going to get drowned out so
the way to deal with this the way to
solve the problem is to have TV show
creators and movie directors Etc that
are willing to take a risk that are
willing to offend your base audience to
understand that when they do a Star Trek
Musical that a lot of people are going
to go Star Trek music or what and freak
out
musical episode has been the most
divisive thing I think I've ever seen on
any Star Trek Forum people are going
nuts over it now people went nuts over
the lower decks episode but that came
out so beautifully I think the lovers
outweighed the haters a little bit but
the musical really does seem to be 50
50. now I I've already told you I'm on
the don't like it side but that's
because I don't like musicals as much as
anything else I just wanted a Star Trek
episode I don't feel it won't Star Trek
because it was a musical it was a
musical Star Trek episode I just wanted
Star Trek but a lot of people have got
quite angry now I see loads and loads of
comments on this group saying look if
you didn't like it just shut up
don't keep commenting I'm sick of this
hearing it and I'm like no that's not
right either
this is an open Forum we do live in a
free country in a free Society we're
actually both opinions matter so if you
didn't like Star Trek this episode you
have a right to say so I have a right to
say so it doesn't mean I hate Star Trek
it means I didn't like that episode and
we can say it but the fact that I didn't
like that episode is a good thing
because it means the Star Trek creators
are taking risks they're not doing a
beige Bland boring franchise or season
of Star Trek now I was speaking to one
of my friends the other day and he says
he actually hated the crossover episode
and I was just like the Riker maneuver
and he was just like I hated it hated
every moment of it it was silly it was
stupid I didn't like it I was like well
you must have absolutely detested the
musical episode then he's like nah loved
it thought it was great proper classic
Star Trek that is fantastic I loved
every moment of it
light bulb moment I want to see that
more in all of the television shows I
watch I expect to have the odd episode I
really don't like if a TV show is being
brave
and really trying to make exciting
interest in sci-fi they are going to do
stuff you don't like but then they'll do
something you absolutely adore
if you want to sign television you have
to take the highs with the lows
but it doesn't mean you can't moan about
it when there is something you don't
like
that's kind of what Twitter's for or
whatever Twitter's called now
X I don't know but guys you can also get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you think because that's another
place that you can safely talk about the
things you like and don't like as long
as you show at least a little bit of
respect to each other
so get in there and tell me exactly what
you think about this idea of it being
exciting television and the need to move
away from Bland boring beige television
and the fact that yes sometimes that
means we're going to get shows we don't
like so much but it also means we're
gonna get some shows we adore get into
the comments and tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
follow all these links that have been
scrolling across the bottom they're all
in the description as well particularly
the patreon go on there that really
supported channel that allows us to keep
going and you even get a free gift after
three months which hey you can't argue
with that as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]